in the beginning when people would kind
of hit you with this like ah I thought
you were this but it it was amazing did
you appreciate that Honesty or would it
would it mess with you a little bit well
it always messed with me yeah um I told
Albert Brooks one time and and uh he a
genius he was on The Tonight Show and uh
he came out and he said he did something
with some like something on the desk it
was like a little trick or did something
and Carson laughed and he says thank God
that's it's not your whole act um cuz
something happened to the card right and
Albert Brook says to Johnny Carson he
says God imagine imagine booking katop
and um American Airlines loses his
luggage he doesn't he doesn't have [__]
right so I'm watching this on and I
remember exactly where I was I was on a
tour we just finished doing this big
like Arena gig at a college and it just
killed and we were watching it on TV on
the bus and I was like what the [__] and
I was so mad
and I was so mad because of what he said
was true yeah so I'm like if the Rolling
Stones luggage was lost they wouldn't
have a [__] act yeah of course so it
made no sense to he's ripping on me if
katop lost his luggage he was [__]
well so if the Rolling Stones or Nirvana
or anyone
else anybody if if the airlines lose
this your [__] you're probably [__]
too but he just singled me out so like
that that was [__] so I get to meet
him at Gary shandling's funeral and all
places there he is and I said I walked
up to him I said I got a beef with you
and you Al Brooks is like oh my God I
got to get a video of this Carrot Top
has a beef with me I can't wait to hear
and I said no it's just you you I so I
tell him the story and he go oh my God I
am the I am the worst person in the
planet I did do that I did say that and
you are correct and I said I know I'm
correct that's what I'm telling you like
everyone could even if you lost your
luggage you wouldn't have anything and
he says I'm so can can we hug it out and
he hate me hugging he says I'm and you
know we're best friends I just had to
set that straight with him I'm like yeah
you know I of course you know why why
pick on me you you you took the words
out of my mouth cuz I was going to ask
if you ever had a like a awkward runin
hashing it out with someone oh I've had
a couple but you know that one was yeah
that one it was just there's been a
comment or two that um people said that
don't know the truth of it that that uh
like when uh our buddy a very very funny
comedian passed away
uh does the clip of me and chairman of
the board he was on
Conan nor McDonald thank you yeah he
would he said on Conan O'Brien one night
yeah and it's such a famous clip because
he's he sets him up for it and he's he's
picking on the poor Courtney Thorne
smith who's on the the movie yeah and it
was a good movie chairman of the board
um he's like God he's going on and on
about so you so you you quit you you
quit friends or what is it melrose's
place you quit melrose's place to go
into movies with katop she goes no I
didn't qu it was one movie and Scott he
is the nicest guy in the and he is
actually a great actor and he's like no
but get go back to this so why would you
go you're you why would you go do a
movie with katop and you have you had
and she's she kept trying to defend me
she's like it was great fun it was a
great movie and uh he's a sweet
guy um and then he's just like I I I
just don't get it he wouldn't let it go
and then McDonald's he says what what
was the name of the movie again and she
says chairman of the board he goes oh Bo
like b o r e d yeah and Conan is you
losing his mind laughing and again I'm
thinking [__] we did that on the set
that's like H we when we were making the
movie we called it chairman of the board
yeah yeah but he thought that was the
most so everywhere I go people say oh my
God were you enorm enemies cuz he really
ripped on you I'm like no one were
comics and two it was a [__] joke it
was and it was funny I had another comic
one time that I opened for at a
uh a college and they wanted me to do 20
minutes and it's is at the time of my
career where I I I had about eight
minutes yeah so I said and I'm not
kidding you I said I got I got about
eight you go 8 minutes I said about
Seven's good but I can stretch it to
eight but you know don't s going to be
honest with you and they said okay they
were fine with it because they didn't
need to have that much time right I said
do even if you just do five I said five
I can do I can nail five so I uh I get
up there and I'm I'm I do two two prop
maybe three do my crime watch thing I
opened with the crime watch that I was
killed and then I go grab this car it
was like a a car that was in the shape
of a ramp so if you had a head on
collision you jump it right and and and
I and everyone kills and I put it this
is 3 years ago I put it down and then I
my I look over and the guy's going like
you know wrap it up and I'm thinking I'm
like like wrap it up like close cuz I
own had done less than a minute yeah and
he's like no no like rap so I I [__] so
I I go to my closer which was this paper
cups and string phone yeah and it was uh
had you know hello what's going on you
feel you know the cups and string phone
I said I made it I made a new one for
today's kids that had a call waiting in
it so I say hold on I have another call
hello and another cup would come out and
then I'd have three cups in conference
calling and I had a clear cup for caller
ID I know it's you I can see you pick up
so that was my big closer and it killed
it killed yeah and so that's when George
Carlin come to me and says that's funny
[__] right there so I do I do I do that
and then the comedian comes out and he
whispers leave your
[__] CU I was going to move it because I
didn't want him to stand you know he
said leave your [__] so I'm all right so
I go into the arena and I watch the
whole the whole set and he wasn't doing
well and he was just he was in a bad
mood and he kept he kept kind of looking
down at at my props and kind of kind of
wanting to move them and Scoot them and
[__] with him he was kind of just doing
with his foot like the [__] and finally
he picks up this car that had the ramp
on
it and he holds it up like no one's
laugh he just holds it up and looks at
the audience like uh yeah this yeah and
then he he he like threw it down he
didn't like lay it down he kind of threw
it down and the crowd was like ooh
because they really love me I was young
I was probably 19 yeah they start to boo
him like like don't don't and he was
like yeah cuz he was kicking my props
and the crow was like they're like Boo
he's like no no no no no the topper come
me the Topper's fine the topper so I I
come off and I'm like well I was the pro
so I came off to say hi he wouldn't say
hi and he left and about 10 years
goodbye of him ripping on me in every
show every show and finally I'm here in
LA and and and I was staying at this
hotel and the elevator doors opened and
and off I'm walking is is this guy no
way and I said oh my God hey oh and he
was like Hey topper and I said no we
have to have a talk and he's like we we
do oh this would be good I said no
really if you have just five minutes of
your time I need to talk to you he said
you got about five okay topper what is
it I said when to set the record
straight what happened he says I'll tell
you before you tell me we're at
University of Georgia I said nope we're
at Wake Forest say you're already wrong
is Wake Forest University he go all
right now what happened you went up and
did 30 I said there you go I did not I
did three props because I didn't even
have 30 minutes I did three props I was
supposed to do 20 18 or something like
that but I did three and then you
started kicking everything he says I
didn't K he remembered I didn't kick it
babe I I said whatever you did you made
it bad for everybody and you turn and
then so you owed me an apology I think
he said let me think on it babe
okay yeah and I swear to God and then I
left and I was like really okay and was
was David Spade one day and David Spade
knows this person real well and com
walking in the corner he says hey I said
how do you how do you know David I said
well David and I are friends I said
David and I you and I should be friends
too and I I said dve he's not my friend
because he thinks that I went to too
long at he got the college wrong and the
amount of time wrong that I did and he
things like that and David is like k
doesn't have five minutes how could you
think he would have and he even know me
he just said how would carop doesn't
have five minutes I said right not even
now do I have five minutes so finally it
was it was like a truce I think he said
all right truce and then I end up going
to a basketball game uh NBA basketball
All-Star Game in Vegas and they put me
in these seats and and um I I had the
like the best seats in the in the
arena I mean Lally ESPN people were
behind me I kep oh God there's like it's
was like I like ESPN guys I go sorry I
got and then who comes and sits right
behind me my friend and I
said I said this sucks huh and he said
uh he said it's okay babe I said you
know I I got to be I got to I got to
know is is it that I'm sitting in front
of you make you more angry or or my hair
you can't see be around it and uh he
said no it's that my son is your biggest
fan would you mind taking a picture with
him
and I said your son is and he goes yeah
and I said oh my God now that got to be
the worst part right he says just take
the picture I said got to make your
blood boil that your son loves me he
says my son loves kerat so I said okay
and I my arm around him I said you know
your dad hated me for
years and he think the son is you know
funny he say he guess my dad hates
everybody that hates me too don't you
know get over
it